one of our deepest longings deeper than
we even perhaps recognized day to day is
that other people should acknowledge
certain of our feelings we want that at
key moments our sufferings should be
understood our anxieties noticed and our
sadness lent legitimacy
we don't want others necessarily to
agree with all our feelings but what we
crave is that they at least validate
them when we are furious we want another
person to say I can see that you've been
driven to distraction it must feel very
chaotic for you inside right now when
we're sad we want someone to say I know
you're unusually down and I understand
the reasons why and when we can't take
it all anymore we want someone gently to
utter it's been too much for you hasn't
it
I recognize that so well of course it
has it all sounds desperately simple and
in a way it is and yet how little of
this emotional nectar of acknowledgement
we ever in fact receive or gift to one
another the habit of not having one's
feelings properly acknowledged begins in
childhood parents even the most loving
ones frequently stumble in this domain
it's not that they don't theoretically
care intensely for their children it's
that they don't appreciate that true
care involves regularly reflecting a
child's moods back to him or her rather
than subtly pushing the moods away or
denying that they exist here are some
typical unacknowledged parent-child
exchanges I'm feeling sad don't be silly
you can't be it's the holidays I'm
really worried darling now that's
ridiculous there's just nothing to be
scared of here
I wish there wasn't any school ever ever
don't be so silly you know we have to
leave the house by 8 o'clock in the
morning how different things might go
and what a different sort of adult the
child would have a chance to grow into
if such dialogues were only slightly
tweaked
if for example the parent could say it's
weird isn't it how it's possible to be
sad at the oddest of times even on a
lovely beach holiday or I can see you're
scared that wind really is fierce out
there or it must be really horrible
having double maths all morning
especially after such a nice weekend
there is one big reason why we don't
acknowledge as we might fear the
feelings we push away are all in some
shape or other emotionally inconvenient
or troubling or upsetting we love our
child so much we don't want to imagine
that they might be sad or worried lost
or having a terribly difficult time at
school
furthermore we may operate with a
background view that acknowledging a
difficult feeling will make it far worse
than it actually is
it will mean fostering it unduly or
giving way to it entirely we fear that
if we give a bit of unbiased mirroring
to our child
we might be encouraging them to grow
cataclysmically depressive unfeasibly
timid or manically resistant to
Authority what we're missing is that
most of us once we've been heard become
far less rather than far more inclined
to insist on the feelings we're beset by
the angry person gets less rather than
more enraged once the depth of their
frustration has been recognised the
rebellious child grows more not less
inclined to buckle down and do their
homework wants their feelings that they
want to burn the school down break the
Headmaster's glasses and abscond to a
desert island have been listened to and
identified with for maybe no more than
55 seconds feelings get less strong not
more tyrannous as soon as they've been
given an airing we become bullies when
no one's listened never because they've
listened too much the problem of
unacknowledged feelings doesn't sadly
end with childhood couples routinely put
each other through the same mill for
example sometimes I feel that you don't
listen
that has to be rubbish I put so much
work into this relationship I'm worried
I might be fired
that's not possible you work so hard all
the way to the divorce
quartz or an affair the good news is
that an enormous uplift in mood is
available right now with very little
effort if we simply learn to change the
way that we typically respond to the I
statements of those who matter to us we
only need to play their feelings back to
them even the potentially awkward
feelings for a few moments using certain
magical phrases I can hear that you must
you must be feeling so I can understand
completely that such phrases can change
the course of lives crucially we don't
need to be listened to by everyone we
can bear an awful lot of unacknowledged
feelings when just a few people some of
them in our childhood and ideally one of
them now in our bedroom and another in
our Friendship Circle every now and then
plays us back to us
the ranter the person animated by a
rigid desire that everyone should listen
to them hasn't of course been over
indulged they're just playing out the
frightening consequences of never having
been heard when it mattered
there is almost no end to what we may be
ready to do for those who pay us that
immense psychologically redemptive honor
of once in a while acknowledging what
we're actually feeling
however momentarily odd melancholy or
inconvenient
it might be our emotional first-aid kit
provides a set of useful selves to some
of life's most challenging psychological
situations including friendship love sex
work and self click the link on screen
now to find out more